President Trump went to Iowa last night
where he celebrated the latest
Republican victory he also used his
first campaign style rally since April
to let on his frustration over ongoing
investigations and his treatment by the
press Margaret Brennan is at the White
House with the president's message to
his supporters Margaret good morning
good morning well with an approval
rating below 40% and his agenda
challenged in Washington President Trump
returned to campaign style rhetoric in
Iowa State he won by 10 points and spent
much of the more than hour-long speech
promising to upend the establishment
it's always terrific to be able to leave
that Washington swamp cheered on by more
than 5,000 Iowa supporters president
Trump unveiled two proposals barring new
immigrants from receiving welfare and
turning his proposed border wall with
Mexico into a massive solar panel but
the higher it goes the more valuable it
is it's like pretty good imagination
right good my idea mr. Trump again
called for unity following the shooting
of Republican Congressman Steve Scalise
hopefully our nation emerges from this
ordeal it was an ordeal terrible more
unified and more determined than ever
before
minutes later dismissed Democrats there
obstructionists their obstructionist
slam journalists the dishonest media
corporations and downplayed the ongoing
FBI probe into Trump campaign associates
they have phony witch hunts going
against me he relished Republican
resilience in congressional election
victories including South Carolina and
Georgia all we do is win win win we won
last night there were some obvious signs
of frustration from the president who
briefly mentioned the death of otto
warmbier set to be buried today
following 17 months in a North Korean
prison look at Otto beautiful Otto
went over there a healthy wonderful boy
and you see how he came back in spite of
his attempts to forge a French
but China's leader Xi Jinping president
Trump suggested that policy is failing
to rein in nuclear-armed North Korea I
wish we would have a little more help
with respect to North Korea from China
but that doesn't seem to be working out
charlie the Iowa rally coincided with
news that the Trump campaign will hold
their first twenty20 election fundraiser
next week at the family-owned Washington
hotel
Margaret thanks